hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to
you guys really wanted me to play this
and you may be listening to me and be
like i didn't really want you to play
this but there were a lot of people that
wanted me to play this and maybe it's
just because i played simulator games in
the past but for some reason people were
really adamant about me playing gas
station simulator and of all the
simulator games out there this one seems
like an odd choice but i'm gonna play it
anyway oh
the lag so
i don't know if i'm going to become a
gas station or if i have a gas station
that i need to get up to snuff for
wonderful travelers to stop by and get
their sustenance and car sustenance and
also people can [ __ ] on the ceiling in
my bathroom i have a funny feeling i'm
going to be cleaning up a lot of poop
off my ceiling literally anywhere but
where the toilet is where i'm going to
be cleaning poop also does that man have
a zipper that goes all the way down his
crotch and up the back so these pants
come off in two pieces out that way
that's what that looks like
oh
oh oh look at dude oh my god
that bobblehead's the best thing i've
ever seen
[Music]
oh i'm the guy on the
loading screen
[Music]
ah interesting
okay all right okay i'm down i seem to
be going 15 miles an hour but
for some reason i really don't think
that's true
[Music]
okay
i
i guess i'm about to make my dream come
true
just that easy you gotta pull into the
spot when it says for sale and you own
it okay
all right
oh god this place is a hell hole also i
didn't realize that my uh my lights are
in uh horror mode hang on we can't have
that i don't think this is a horror game
but who knows
you know gas station there could be many
things lurking in the darkness spooky
ghosts crawling through the walls
werewolves howling in the desert
distance the
huffle the huffalompagus the
fluffle the huffle lumpus the huffle
lump of the huffalumpagus the huffle
what is the name of the huffalompagus
awfully pumbly there we go sorry i had
to stall until i got that all right
let's make a gas station figure out how
to enter the gas
station don't know choose my
snake i choose snake i choose snack
snake is my teammate i have trash i have
trash
all right i'll i'll put there
oh
throw it into the trash okay i thought i
thought my arm was a little stronger
than that
boom
[Music]
i missed but okay you consider me
you say you say i hit it i you know i
trust you
and that definitely okay whatever from
down freaking town from
if this doesn't go in i quit the game
right now and i never play it again okay
[Music]
it didn't go in but the game counted
that it did so
whatever if the game said i did then i
did and everybody shut up hello can i
have this
oh
oh god
oh god i actually have to clean this
place up oh i do don't i
all right you got me all right i'll make
a goddamn get oh my god
there are flies in my eyeballs holy hell
this place is awful
oh my god follow the high voltage cable
and find a way to turn on the
electricity the high voltage what now
what do you see in high voltage cable
what the hell oh no
yes yes yes yes
ah
okay
right i'll just go to the trash heap
over here okay here we go
i do oh i'm flying i'm flying i'm flying
i'm rising to the sky
i'm ascending
wow
oh
not enough money i don't even have five
bucks to my name
that's how poor i am i spent every dime
i had on this place and if it doesn't
succeed then i am
so screwed
i am just going to be a travesty of a
human being and also apparently my game
can't frickin run this what is with you
i've had enough of you
i've had enough of this okay pick up the
phone at the booth in the front of the
station
okay someone calling me is someone
calling me or am i
okay it's still it's still running like
poop i apologize everybody the graphic
fidelity i'm just gonna turn down to
tits all right we got tits graphics
oh that's not so good let's try medium
it's okay guys i only have a 30 90. you
know someday i am gonna go to the two
computer method but god i just really
don't want to i know it's like everyone
already does like the two computer
method for recording but i just i live
in like 2014 of recording videos and i
just cannot upgrade i could never i
cannot do it i can't handle it
but also a 30 90 should be able to
handle this hello congratulations on
your purchase and investment little
nephew hi
it has been a while since you've heard
my voice now yeah never i've never heard
it yes i'm a busy person
but
luck would have it that the land you've
purchased once belonged to my father oh
since you are not only a potential
business partner but family no less i'll
do my best to help you okay i will send
you emails on a regular basis providing
you with information on how to handle
each part of the business okay
do make sure to pay attention uh-huh
well
i must head off now
it was pleasant speaking to you i didn't
say a word
anki uh so unk uh
didn't i didn't really get any
information i have a computer
do i have a computer i do have a
computer apparently there's a computer
in this hell hole there is a computer
wow no that's a monitor that is not a
computer
oh wow
okay howdy howdy indeed or greetings and
salutations the dialect never really was
my forte regardless i've just heard you
made a solid investment though i pity
the fact you had to sell your car for it
what did i do you could have always
asked me for a loan i'll pitch in with a
few tips and tricks my emails will come
periodically don't worry about money for
this part where family and family keeps
an eye on each other's backs i'm here to
lend a helping hand and a man like me
puts my money where they about nowadays
okay
thanks unk
go to the mini excavator the what hint
her name is rudy okay rudy
all right roods
okay
oh
rudy
rudy sand piles in front of the gas pump
okay roods
i'm out of gas
ironic isn't it yes it is
yes it actually is this game is far more
involved than i thought it would be i
was not mentally prepared for something
of this magnitude
oh
holding jerry clan
can click lmb on the distributor to
replenish it once it's full click lmb on
the excavators
i'm guessing i gotta fill up the can
oh yeah i have a gas station but you
know what i didn't assume that there
would actually be gas in it yet
but i guess there is
okay
oh
when the exhaust turns red hold right
mouse button to cool the engine
okay
all right i'm gonna remove the sand
piles now
do i just know apparently i don't just
drive over them
what am i supposed to do what do i do
what do i do what do i do
what do i do
oh
cool engine
dunk okay i did it open the gas station
for customers when you don't have time
to serve customers close the gas station
again so you can focus on your other
responsibilities you got it also how am
i cooling these am i peeing on this am i
pissing on this am i pissing am i
pissing on this i'm gonna leave rudy
right there
all right open for business hello police
officer you need some gas
i'm open for business
that's shockingly amazing that's very
good you can open close a gas station at
any time use a downtam to organize a gas
station or do other activities that you
can find right next to the lever there
is a button that resets traffic
how does that work
this will reset all the cars and
customers
how do i select okay cancel okay
okay do i have to throw it in the
dumpster
i mean is that a thing that i have to do
i'm guessing no
man it's a stye in here okay let's see
what other
delivery fuel supply
oh
too handy please got it nailed it dude i
have mail
new ryder cannon opening closing
ordering you can only order fuel for now
okay
all right i am a gas station connoisseur
hey how you doing hey can i help you in
some gas hello how are you i will love
the way you just clicked through that
door
hey can i help you what are you doing
over there can i
can i assist you uh you need some gas i
i don't have fuel uh pardon me ma'am if
you just wait the truck is right over
there man the truck is right over there
wait a minute hold on there's a truck
right over there hey hold on hold on
lady wait for it i have some fuel on the
way why don't you just wait a second
lady there's fuel right over there and
i'm going to get it to you
oh no there's fuel coming in
lady i believe that there's just a huge
desire right there it's coming in very
hot and fresh you want the fuel it's
going to be right there how are you
going to get trapped in the desert if
you don't get the fuel
fine
fine hi can i get some fuel
can you put some fuel in my tank
hey take your time buddy hey no hurry
here hey come on now hey go for it hey
hurry up a little bit hey all right
is that elon musk is this elon elon
elon things not go so well in space
is mars okay
all right anyway bye test your skills on
the archive while you wait for your next
assignment no i won't because i've got
customers to fuel hey
big spender
hey
here comes mr
moneybags sorry madame moneybags
sorry pardon me
hey
you want some fuel you know you get fuel
you know you i have
are you kidding me what do you mean
there's fuel right here
can you
oh wait
i have to do this you know i assume that
with um with you know a fuel delivery
that there would be like some anyway hey
how you doing let me top you off there
oh let's starting boost that okay and
then bam oh got it
i didn't know that i needed to click
again before i got that anyway thank you
very much for your patronage ah your
windows are a little dirty all right
don't give me that look but uh you have
a lovely day now you have a lovely day
now you have a lovely day now
you have a lovely day now all right you
take care now you take care elon you
take care all right you don't worry
you'll get your dreams again don't worry
you'll get them you'll get them buddy
you'll get them pal hey you'll get him
hey don't worry about it you'll get him
buddy you'll get him buddy you'll get
him pal all right
what the hell
[Music]
there's a snake in my gas okay well
first customer satisfied and next
customer is coming in right now i can
already tell come on in bring her in
okay
well it's kind of [ __ ] you know i
guess i'll clean up the place
whatever
put away here
a customer
a customer hey lovely car oh lovely
muscles oh lovely mohawk hey
how you doing pal love the nip love that
nip love that face love that schnoz and
love that hair i'm gonna get you taken
care of buddy you keep those veins in
check
careful a paper cut might kill you buddy
but uh you're looking good you're
looking hot and fresh hey would you like
some gas don't worry i'll uh starting
boost ya oh yeah
you have a lovely day too
you have a lovely day now you have a
lovely day take care of that
you know what i'm saying all right you
have fun here surprise the car doesn't
wobble when you get in oh wow
yes i'm the best i'm the best
i'm a capitalistic god
well
this is a whole lot of nothing happening
test your skills on arcade while okay
anybody coming in
hey
how you doing hey come on in bring her
in all right come on in hey right here
right up here hey come on in hey this is
a full service gas station if you know
what i'm talking about i'm talking primo
service all day every day you come here
my way i'll make sure you leave with a
smile all ain't you just a peach you
have cash right good clad clad good glad
hey weather's holding up pretty good
right
weather's holding up real good oh my god
oh
there you go incredible i know
i know i feel that good hey i don't i do
more than just fuel things good i'm
always on target if you know what i mean
hey you have a lovely day all right take
care
another sweet sale
all right i'm gonna go test my skills on
the arcade apparently because that's
what i'm supposed to do no beer
beer
lies lies and slander
lies and slander all right let's see
what's going on the junk keep
[Music]
oh finished the race before okay go i'm
going
oh god
oh come on
those things controls are a little funky
it'd be a lot easier with a joystick i'm
the best i'm the best
ah
now this is pod racing okay come on
uh
jump ramp jump boing oh
this was a mistake
where am i yes yes i have a customer at
the fuel but it doesn't matter
oh god oh god okay you know what i'm
done i have customers i can't bother
with you right now i've got customers
waiting to be fueled up and i'm gonna
feel them good and howdy hey how you
doing i'm sorry i was so late
i will service you now
here i already wait i already know how
to do this i've been doing this for a
while can you get off
[Music]
i know i'm a life saver
buy a trash bag and equip it buy a trash
bag why do i need to buy a trash bag
yeah all right
is it does it get delivered or something
do i i have it
okay
pick up some okay all right
okay i'm cleaning okay
oh god there she goes
empty the trash cans outside of your
station with a trash bag okay you got it
hey
i'll be right with you sir and or madam
oh yes
hey how you doing hey welcome welcome
hey how's it going old timer hey how you
doing or should i say young sprout
grasshopper even hey how you doing you
look like a cool guy you look like a
cool dude oh my god
oh
how are you friend
good to
see you from the inside anyway i'll fuel
you up now
i'll get you taken care of and
good job i know
i know
i know i do like cleaning up i got no
problem with that i just don't know why
i needed to wait until i got
an arcade game in
okay i'm just guessing it's not a
problem if they go flying off into the
distance but uh
i'm not gonna do anything to fix it
is this trash
looks like trash
what do you mean task complete my place
is still dirty why would you think i'd
be done okay bye
okay bye
that's fine
okay
tab buy a broom okay buy a broom broom
broom broom broom buy a broom okay i got
a broom okay broom
okay
the dirtiness bar
this is moderately less satisfying than
power washing simulator i don't think
broomings and the sound
ah
okay i can spam click and it's easier
okay i've found an exploit already okay
that's better i don't have to hear the
sound then
all right i'm the best
order garbage collection using a
computer okay can do can i not broom
this no
oh hi oh hey how you doing oh good to
see you hey how you been oh yeah you do
hey how are you how you been how you
doing how's the family
you're welcome fueled it better i know i
did i know it did i know i did what am i
doing delivery garbage collection please
thank you
hi dennis dennis hula a freaking horror
game jesus christ that was the scariest
thing i've ever seen dennis eat
eat [ __ ] dennis what the hell
dennis
there's a
dennis stop
dennis i threw all my [ __ ] away
all right okay hang on
get [ __ ] dennis i will throw a brick
at your eye
get wrecked dennis yeah i should be out
you're lucky i don't have a sledgehammer
get out of here
you know you're dennis
oh you are an [ __ ] school's good for
you
freaking dennis
the jumpscare king him being just
someone laughing and looking around the
corner might be one of the scariest
things i've ever seen
okay colored palette uh let's do a nice
nice desert mauve
oh yeah
too far
i have taken this too far
oh i see what it is okay i didn't
realize how it was
hello oh garbage collection okay
well that's fun
is that a customer i hear
or is that just the sound of the garbage
truck
customer customer
customer
yay
i'll work that shoulder out for you just
give me a second i'll
i'll be right with you
all right and
[Music]
cool
you got it pal you got it pal you got it
you got it don't mind the
don't mind the shoddy paint job i'm
touching up the place making it looking
pristine hey i'll have the bathrooms
ready in a jiffy just come back tomorrow
to your favorite gas station
markiplier's gas station look the
youtube channel didn't work out too well
for me but hey
i got gas out the ass and i'll put gas
in your ass
i need to work on my slogans but hey
you'll get gas
pull your ass
get some gas pull your ass up get some
gas up in your ass i gotta stop talking
about ass bring your car round
i'll give your ass a pound
[Music]
this place is looking nice
this place is looking real nice
and i got another customer hey
it's probably because my uh
gas station's looking so primo
looking pretty good hey
hey pal i'll be right with you is this
the right color wait a minute wait
wait
wait wait a minute have i not had the
right color this whole time
oh oh oh oh oh
hi hey how are you doing hey good to see
you hey i'll put some gas in your ass
yeah cool um
i love painting it's just like that's
the thing about it i love painting i
especially love painting over stuff that
i've already painted
almost there
almost got it
do i have to paint the oh i have to
paint the corners too
ah this is like power wash simulator and
the tediousness
i know i don't know if i want to paint
these the same color as the other one i
think these might need to be like a
darker color
oh yeah that's looking nice
i don't know about it uh maybe green
might might be good for this
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no it's grown on me it's grown on me
it's grown on me ah it's grown on me
someone get it off it's grown on me i
like it you know what i think i like it
find the right tool to break into the
car trunk
what what what
what
lock picking what am i trying to lock
pick here
oh hey copper uh wasn't trying to lock
pick anything what are you doing here
well this is an awfully inconvenient
time for you to show up hey let me fuel
up your ass
hey you came for the ass treatment did
you do the ass flyers was it the ass
advertisements that really brought you
in here
hey let me give you a nice highway uh
discount there buddy why don't you just
uh
oh not much
[Music]
saver yeah yeah yes or you maybe okay
okay
okay so it's like skyrim lock picking
okay got it okay dust bowl pan it can't
be opened i don't know what i just got
what did i just get are you telling me
that there are other paint colors that i
just spent all this time painting my
goddamn gas station and you're telling
me that there are other paint colors
that i could have the whole time all
right
i guess i'll paint some
more what color is that what color is it
what color do you have oh i never i
don't have any color okay all right i'm
gonna go this green
you know at first i didn't like it but i
like the boldness of it you know i think
the boldness of it is really gonna bring
people in the boldness is good the
boldness is good i already how do i not
i can't you can't bail out of painting
something ever you can never bail
you can only finish the paint no
i love repainting
i love it
i love it why is there no way to not
paint i thought i was gonna paint like
the windowsill or something but no
looks like i just gotta keep going
huh
is this whole thing gonna go green the
whole goddamn thing oh my god the whole
thing holy crap
okay well that was a bout of efficiency
i like that
well i don't know if i like the color
but i mean i like that it happened
quickly
hi
how you doing an old dimer with the
mohawk
nice
nice let me get you let me get you let
me get you
let me get you got let me get you got
i've kind of almost forgotten that this
is a gas station simulator but there's
so many different facets to gas stations
that you wouldn't understand
i know
i know my friend
i am aware
that it is nice
[Music]
okay and now it's looking pretty spiffy
you know at first i didn't know if i
liked the green accents and i'm not sure
i still do but it does look good
it doesn't look that good it looks bad
actually it looks it looks bad i.e let
me see what this looks like
nah
nah it's got to be the same accents it's
going to grow on me it's going to grow
on me the dark green kind of like
teal-ish
it's an interesting color but i'm an
interesting dude and this is an
interesting hey
welcome aboard hey hop on pop here hey
what you doing hey you need some pumped
you need some bum you need a little off
the top you know what i'm saying you
need a little off the top what do you
want what do you want customers order
what do you uh what do you want what are
you what are you ordering you're
ordering uh primo primo unleaded
okay
cool amazing
i know fuel status is low okay delivery
give me fuel give me fire give me that
which i desire
that
is acceptable right hang the dust bowl
painting inside the gas station
i'm sorry the what
oh oh god
okay well let's uh never forget the dust
bowl i guess
this way i'll always know hmm
you know my instinct my first instinct i
always gotta trust that buy two shelves
okay you got it
features shelves uh
yes bye big
[Music]
bye big
do i have them in my bag already oh i do
i do i do i do i do okay um
okay here we go here we go here we go
oh yeah oh yeah
not quite
is that even no
what
why is it not even
why it's not eve why would you
i'm not gonna even equip it i'm not even
gonna equip it because i wasn't even
that's probably what it was i wasn't
even therefore it wasn't even do i have
to do this yes apparently
give me the gas thanks elon hi how you
doing hey welcome hey you want some
snacks i'll have some snacks set up real
quick
just hold on okay i think i have to be
even first
and then you pull it out yeah yeah yeah
that's it that's the one
that's it that's it that's it that's it
boom
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah hang on
bam baby bam baby bam
bam and i got security well
what is that okay never mind that's not
good
what's that what is that what is that
what is that get out of here
hi
you want some gas hey here you go pal
here you go pal
shut up shut up buy additional parking
space via the pc how does that work
oh
okay i'm gonna have to no i see i see
what i'm gonna have to when i see
can i make the purchase before cleaning
the area rudy
all right rudy
rudy
where is this parking space i think it
was over there yeah that's it that's it
that's it
blam sand gone
parked perfectly
all right let's uh do whatever the hell
else we needed to do buy that parking
lot that's right
okay bye
bought
it's been bought
it's been bought i bought it
i bought it answer the call from the
uncle why is the uncle's name so ominous
hello the uncle
hello
i see the business is doing well i'm
calling to congratulate you on
successfully getting it off the ground
but
you can't run a business on fuel alone
i've had a few of my people deliver some
extra stock for those empty shelves of
yours
time to talk money
you now owe me okay
i'll send you the invoice to your email
don't miss it i'm sorry nephew but there
is just no room for charity in this
world
i hope you'll find it within your
finances to repay the debt
otherwise we'll be forced to see to more
persuasive methods of reimbursement
don't have me wait too long now
you're bi
okay uncle
what was with your feet what was with
your feet i saw that this is a horror
game
oh i knew it i knew it
bam
uh did you say that there was someone at
the register
serve the customer at the cash register
every product that falls into the basket
without being scanned or falls out of
the checkout goes to the customer for
free what are you talking about
what are you talking about
wait how much do i have to pay my uncle
five
thousand dollars
what do you mean
five minutes to pay five thousand
dollars but it's impossible i can't get
out god damn this god damn it why did i
have to get a big shelf
why i've really ruined it rude can i get
a small shelf can i get a small snack
small food stand here we go that's
better oh hi wow you are there um hang
on hang on hey hang on hang on no no
that's not right here we go
straight on here we go snacks perfect
and bam done can you put the snacks on
this hello
i thought i had snacks on this
hello
left shift to move the belt now okay
put the products over the scanner i'll
get dirty over the time to slow down
clean it up by holding the right mouse
button and swiping over the belt okay
make no mistake to increase combo and
get a tip
i don't think that's common
give me that okay i'll take that
okay
[Music]
that'll do it thank you thank you you
have a little day now you have a lovely
day now you live a little lovely day hey
how you doing you have are you gonna
ready to have a lovely day you ready to
have a lovely day okay i need to pay
this goddamn loan
um i'll pay ten dollars
was that my uncle
i paid i made the money and i could i
need a delivery i need food i don't know
you uh the other shelf kind of didn't
have food
i don't have food
i got no money okay
um
i have no money uncle
uncle please
please
i don't have the money
uncle
hey ma'am i'm having a bit of a crisis
at the moment
you owe me money
fueling superstar uh unk unk please unk
uh unk have mercy unk
unk
oh
no well whatever i need to figure out
how to put this goddamn shelf here
no uh well that doesn't have it either
oh
oh never mind okay
how did i do that
ah
face place place place place okay place
got it
okay we're good we're good we're good if
i have any hi
come on in you got my name on your shirt
i don't know why i said it like that
have a good day browsing peruse peruse
away please
okay thank you for putting that in my
trash can thank you for putting that in
my trash can you can buy anything you
can buy anything you want to buy in
something
okay thank you me
wrap ruse peru's away my friend peruse
you ready to uh you ready
here we go and
oh uh
i know
only the top quality service here at
markiplier's gas station you just
remember the name my friend you remember
the name
you remember the name i gotta take the
trash out here you go blam
wow what a lovely day and what a lovely
hi come on in hey don't be shy don't run
away where are you running off to hey
don't run away come back in what are you
doing we'll come back into my shop you
got something you said bye you haven't
done anything yet you haven't bought
anything what are you doing you think
you're going to go away yeah where are
you going to go where are you going to
go if you don't have any gas you can't
go anywhere if you don't have any gas
you can't go anywhere if you don't have
any tires either or any food food is
basically gas for your body
okay anyway how's it going
i got you
i know
i know okay
time's up don't feel bad about you don't
know
[Music]
where's our goddamn money
what the hell man
oh my god uncle please oh i'm dead
i'm a dead man
uncle how am i gonna pay you back
[Music]
what the hell was this all just a
prologue to something bigger
[Music]
[Applause]
what kind of subplot is this
hi uncle how you doing
wake up sam
you've got a gas station around
okay thanks uncle thank you
okay wow great the uncle okay not my
uncle the uncle
okay hey nephew
back on your feet
i hope your head's no longer spinning
thanks for picking up
we need to talk
there was a mistake a serious one
you can rest easy knowing i will have
the responsible people dealt proper
retribution for what has happened
the amount of time on your investment
loan deadline was rendered far too short
for what the amount was
it's plain bad business
and i don't make bad business decisions
let's forget about this debacle for the
time being as a token of apology please
accept this small gift it will help with
your next delivery no strings attached
however
you will need to make the warehouse
operational again to receive it
somehow
you're a resolute lad
you'll figure it out okay thanks hunk
well
oh
taking a loan is now available the loan
money has been returned to you oh thank
you
oh so all that money was not for for
naught
oh okay
all right
well
looks like i've got a gas station empire
now but i'm all out of time for this
episode so thank you everybody so much
for watching gas station simulator i
don't think i'm going to be playing too
much more of this but this was fun this
was an enjoyable experience can i clean
the walls
the walls really need some cleaning oh
the white interior would be nice for
this this would be nice
oh that is
that's much better okay that's much
better but i don't have time so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down in the
comments below and check out more
simulator games i've played on my
channel i've played quite a few now and
i will continue to play more if you have
an idea for a simulator game that you
want me to play write in the comments
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
oh